is good to be here I'm the king of the
mean I am uh really kind of like a mean
guy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Bobby
can dose people by peeing in their
drinks
you look like you're always on a spirit
quest to find your other sandal
s Uncle laser has the voice of a fat
white woman that smokes three packs of
cigarettes a day
and the hair of a fat white woman that
smokes three packs of cigarette
Uncle laser got his name when he tried
to molest a hologram at a Pink Floyd
concert
laser is what you get when you pour
Mountain Dew on a Chia Pet
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh Gary Faust kids this is what happens
if you don't go through with the school
shooting
okay it's better to be known for
something than to just fizzle out with a
podcast company
it's good to see what Alex Jones would
have looked like if we didn't start
working out
Gary's been sucking on the T I've killed
Tony in the comedy scene without ever
doing comedy he is a [__] kid that
we let shoot a three-pointer at the end
of the game
[Laughter]
[Applause]
welcome to your first and only time on
stage